To help us generalize this now, let's refer to an input image as F index over
i and j, output as G and h[i,j] as the kernel.
And these are the terms you'll be using again and
again throughout some of the stuff we deal with image processings.
Again let's take our nine by time, nine by nine sample image.
This is our three by three kernel with K is equal to 1.
Just to help us do some simple math, I'm now going to take
an element here with a neighborhood, with you know i and j at 3.
So basically now looking for value of g at the output at 3.
We want to figure out what was the math for coming up with this.
And I've given it some variables, A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, I.
Just to kind of mirror the lowercase ones here.
For generality, let's just now play around with just these two for now, and
again, this is the one that is basically moving around inside this.
So G 3,3.
The value here and the output would therefore be the summation of A.
Lower case a with capital A, lower case b, capital B, and doing that for
each and every element, the nine elements here.
So this would be my equation.
Now, since there are nine of these, I do want to always normalize it.
So, actually, I would come up with a scaling factor, 1 over 9,
to help me kind of normalize the values from all of the, them.
For the case of just doing a filter that's an average.
So right now, to do an average, my kernel would just be 1 over 9, 1 over 9,
1 over 9.
Same values in all nine elements.
So now if I do 1 over 9, and this is my image here.
Of course the averaging would be best defined by this equation.
So, G 3,3 basically for a kernel which is an average kernel.
1 over 9,
all, all the nine elements would be 1 over 9 and the summation of all of them.
Very similar to the,
what we had looked in the 1D case now applied to a 2D case here.